L'action de John Wick est un peu différente,
c'est vraiment intense, il en demande juste un
peu plus, c'est
cinq jours par semaine. J'appelle
ça le laboratoire de la violence,
une partie active de l'équipe de chorégraphie
d'avoir quelqu'un qui met autant de
lui-même, c'est du jamais vu.  vraiment
amusant et j'espère que vous apprécierez le chapitre
quatre
[Musique]
avec ce personnage John Wick, nous avons
de nouvelles armes, la seule chose que Chad avait
en tête, il avait des nunchucks
contre des balles AR-15 contre des Chucks
ouais les nunchakus
[Musique]
Je n'ai jamais  Je me suis vraiment bien comporté avec lui, mais je m'en
suis bien sorti,
alors nous essayons de faire en sorte que cela fasse partie
du plaisir
ou d'essayer
[Musique]
Behind Enemy
La Table Cinema
[Applaudissements]